joining me now is ohio congressman jim
jordan ranking member of the house
judiciary committee and lee smith author
and journalist who series the enemy
within how america's elite sold us out
to china gets to the very point of this
open
all right congressman it's a bit rich
don't you think for biden to claim
kind of this folksy demeanor
while his family is benefiting
this entire time from his role in the
federal government
well particularly that statement where
he said i don't think you should get
wealthy just because you're in high
office well there are 4.8 million
reasons why that statement's not true
not accurate because that's what his son
got paid and we now know based on these
text messages and emails that it was a
family enterprise that's what hunter
biden got paid from this chinese energy
company cefc
4.8 million dollars thousands and
hundreds of thousands of dollars each
and every month coming to him and his
uncle part of the family enterprise so
that that just doesn't fly um these guys
have it's been that way for a long time
it's just now starting to come to the
surface and and look the press now has
to admit that what we all said 18 months
ago was true the laptop was real the
eyewitness was real the emails were real
it was all real except for that you know
fake line we got from 51 former intel
experts saying it was russian
disinformation
now now he's also hunter is also we keep
forgetting this he's getting paid
handsomely for really really lame art if
you can call it that
do we know who's buying it why they're
buying it is it just a fascination is it
somebody who wants to influence joe i
mean we don't really have any idea but
it doesn't look like the
white house is worried about the hunter
biden scandal because they're not even
distancing themselves from him he was
actually spotted
at the white house easter egg roll
after kind of keeping that low profile
amid his federal investigation it's the
first time that he's been seen in public
since the washington post authenticated
the emails from his laptop on march 30th
lee are you surprised by this
or that he wasn't in the bunny
yeah that's what i was going to say i'm
surprised he wasn't the person in the
bunny costume he's probably showing up
in lots of different places also all
sorts of sports mascots and whatnot just
to be hanging around look the the the
point about the the biden family the
biden family has been collecting for a
long time and and the way that i look at
it i'm not expecting anyone to to shed
tears on behalf of hunter biden but it's
not just hunter biden he's the nerdy
well kid with substance abuse problems
with problems with women with problems
with money so he's kind of the front man
and he sort of elicits sympathy the
other players behind this are of course
the president of the united states for
whom hunter is effectively a bag man and
uh and uncle jim biden so it's not just
hunter it's the biden family and the
relationship with china is extremely
important because what we're looking at
is the biden family is at the top of a
regime that is structurally pro-china if
you look at democratic party donors
between big tech
hollywood wall street all of them depend
on a cash flow from china and if you
look laura's you were talking about the
different policies especially
breaking the fossil fuel in
energy industry that helps china why are
all of the biden administration's
policies helping the people's republic
of china
now speaking of this relationship with
the ccp today
in an interview the secretary of climate
john kerry he was asked about the
relationship now with china given all
these other issues that are floating
about especially you know obviously he's
focused on the climate question watch
some of the differences of opinion
between our countries have been hardened
and sharpened
uh and that makes the diplomacy more
complicated we need to get things going
but if climate becomes one of the tools
one of the weapons
in the bilateral
back and forth
uh we're cooked we're in serious trouble
no you notice he's talking about being
cooked uh congressman jordan
about climate change when
we have these major geopolitical
struggles going on with the russian
invasion and china helping russia and
obviously the solomon islands security
agreement china is going to have a huge
advantage over us now uh with that new
security arrangement they have of the
solomon islands and he's talking about
climate
change yeah i mean as if that's what the
american people are focused on and i
would just point out too it was it's not
just china with the biden family
remember hunter biden was taking money
from the big energy company in ukraine
he took money from the spouse of the
mayor of moscow so he took money from
all kinds of
foreign interests that that are concerns
and adversaries of the united states um
at the time so that's part of this as
well but where's the issues that the
american people care about where where's
the focus on the border where's the
focus on the price of gasoline four
dollar gas everywhere six dollars in
california where's the focus on the 41
year high inflation rate and you got joe
biden and out doing this and john kerry
talking about climate change for
goodness sake so let's focus on the
things the american people want us to
focus on um i just i don't think the
american people get these folks there's
a reason why joe biden why joe biden's
approval rating is at 33 and some days i
feel like they're intentionally trying
to drive it into the 20s with all the
stupid things they say
the most recent being the fact that
they're going to appeal this mass
decision by the by the federal judge i
mean that that's going to be one of the
craziest things i've heard but they're
going to do it
yeah well lee final word to you on the
biden family business as americans are
struggling now to pay the bills
yeah i mean i just want to hit on
climate for one second the fact is that
climate is the instrument to destroy the
american working and middle class and to
enrich china and that's why joe biden is
there right that's why joe biden is the
avatar and not just for biden family
interest but for the democratic party
and their performative progressive elite
that's what's going on climate is
intended to break the working and middle
american class
now it's definitely going to impoverish
us if we go down this road congressman
lee great to see you both
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else